if you couldn't tell we're in a
different location in fact we're on the
road right now yeah we're in the
beautiful city of london yeah before
you're gonna say the beauty the
beautiful city of england yeah the
beautiful city of the united kingdom
england is my city
and no i'm not from compton
hopefully it looks good we brought our
cameras uh we're using different mics so
hopefully it won't be you know too
different of a trash tasting experience
and uh it should be like this for like
two or three episodes yeah so if you
like the old setup or you like a
different setup we'll mix it up we'll
mix it up sorry we're gonna have a few
weeks here i'm gonna film a few episodes
here uh then we're gonna change places
again because we are on the road right
now uh this is a very like gorilla kind
of setup we kind of brought all of our
equipment from what is
oh my god like i walked in this room and
i'm like this this is like making me
feel nostalgic yeah it's like the old
studio yeah it's like the old studio
there's like the trip hazards are back
here like there's wires everywhere uh
but hopefully we're making it work yeah
yeah but hey welcome back this is i
guess the proper like start to like
season three of trash taste now yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and uh by the time
we're recording this we had just
finished mcm london yeah which i think
by the time of releasing won't be too
far after we went there about two weeks
yeah is it is that yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i'm like i'm like where the [ __ ] are we
and like trash takes time
but yeah uh it was my first mcm london
yeah it's only my second time in london
just in general yeah so mcm is uh i
don't know what it stands for but it's
comic con basically it's comic con it's
like it's london comic-con and it's like
the biggest
everyone has a one comics no but i mean
uh yeah it's uh good to be back there
haven't gone in like three years i mean
this is my first convention since 2019
ax i think it is for all of us yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that was the last
convention we all went to and i believe
the last comic con or the last mcm i
went to was probably 2018 i think no
maybe even 2017 because i went to
momocon like one of the few years and i
was like it's the same weekend as mcm so
it's been a very very long time since
i've been to mcmahon
well irregardless it was a very
different experience yeah because not
only it was our first con in three years
but it was also our first con as trash
taste yeah yeah so we had no idea what
to expect and
i mean a lot of [ __ ] happened yeah sure
yeah i mean it's it kind of put things
into perspective just one like how long
it's been since trash taser started and
two how long it's been since the world
has moved on since trash taser started
yeah because yeah i remember like this
is not not anything to do with uh mcm
but i remember like we met kevin um uh
met kevin and his partner uh kevin
pankin by the way yeah kevin pankins
sorry i should have
it's just just kevin yeah he's just
kidding
you know the kids there's only one god
that's the worst of this god just throws
names out that means nothing to people
so we met our friend bob
yeah you know
don't say anyone's name i would like to
fully explain
so you met kevin penkin who uh has flown
over here to the uk as well
uh and i remember the first thing
uh
his uh his partner says to me is oh
congratulations on everything by the way
and i'm like what what are you talking
about and she's just like you guys have
been killing it and i'm just like so
proud of you guys and i'm like
wait
i haven't met you since before trash
taste started that's so [ __ ] surreal
to me right because i feel like the last
time i met kevin was just like a year or
two ago right right and i'm just like
wait the last time i met kevin trash
taste didn't exist no that was yeah it
was like
it feels like we started it two months
ago but in reality it's been two whole
freaking years yeah yeah yeah it's just
like and that two years though it's just
gone like that yeah you know yeah and
now like meeting people for like meeting
friends who i count as like really
really close friends and them
congratulating me for starting trash
taste is like so [ __ ] weird you know
i'm like start to congratulate starting
trash taste
like episode five
you guys you guys got a long way to go
still meanwhile we had just released a
hundred episodes
make sure you realize how isolated you
are in japan yeah because like you know
yeah
we don't get to speak much english
outside of
like our crew
so it's so like
you know it's like 10 of us
and then no no one else yeah but then
obviously here it's like oh you're
friends oh there's oh their friend knows
trash taste but it's like
our friends don't know outside of like
our group here no one knows trash taste
yeah yeah because they don't they don't
[ __ ] watch english podcasts yeah
suffering with success is that what
we're titling this episode probably yeah
suffering from
suffering
oh god yeah but it was a first mcn for
me um i'd only heard of mcn from these
guys yeah and you know i was like okay
it's it's like what the biggest con in
the uk probably yeah yeah maybe probably
probably by far no it's definitely the
biggest yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry i'm not
the biggest europe though right like no
no that's actually japan i believe
oh anime japan no isn't it no it's
gamescon isn't it in germany i i i i i
was talking about anime let's let's see
whose [ __ ] is the best here i think
i think it might be an anime
i know there's a japan expo in paris
that's gigantic yeah i don't know why
japan something is japanese something
with like
it's got the [ __ ] rotary of like
anime expo japan it's like it's like mix
and match bro it's one of them i don't
know which one it is we're all talking
about the same convention
we don't remember what it is
japan expo yeah i think i think now that
you say japanese food
it's huge i don't know anyone who's gone
to it but i mean that's because british
people i don't know yeah you're like
friends oh god yeah yeah yeah and then
there's gamescon in germany right which
is awesome i've been the gamescom
gamescom is
massive yeah yeah i remember i went to
gamescon and like i was like yeah man i
kind of this is this is when the switch
uh was about to come out right right and
um i remember that uh nintendo had a
booth to play super mario odyssey for
like 10 minutes right and the line was
like eight hours
and it was ridiculous there was like a
japanese woman just standing outside
with like a thing that said like oh the
wait time is like 600 minutes or
something right i was like i was like i
was like what and people were like yo
joining in this cure i'm like you know
the thing closes before this this is
done what do you what what is this math
right yeah but like gamescon is like so
big that also i feel like you can't
really do anything like it gets to a
point where it's almost you know it's
like this has reached a capacity where i
can no longer do anything i think i
played like i i the only games you could
actually get on in a reasonable amount
of times were like the games that were
like destined to [ __ ] fail the moment
they came out yeah games that nobody
gave a [ __ ] about is it kind of like e3
in a sense yeah it's e3 but for europe
but it's right it's i it's open to the
public i think
all days bar won and it was just like it
was insane i i i don't really want to go
back i think if i were to go back it
would be
under
like a press
pass or something where you can just be
like see you losers i'm going in la i'm
gonna go to the front yeah it's just
like i cut the entire line i'm hyped for
like i was hyped for super mario odyssey
but i'm not waiting over an hour hyped
like an hour was pretty much my yeah
i don't think i'm like anything is worth
me waiting an hour in terms of like
games for me like i can't think of a
single game where i'm just like yo okay
two-hour live two-hour wait time for
like a for like a five-minute demo or
something yo let's go let's go i think
the longest i ever waited was like an
hour and a half aaron 40 at tgs to play
persona 5. right was it worth it there
were 40. i mean yeah but you know you
know how long that game is yeah five
minutes is not a lot of time so you know
like you can't do anything you can't
sink your teeth into it
you know what i mean like you're just
teasing and it's like i knew i was gonna
buy it anyway so i was just like at the
end of the iron 40 i got to the front of
the line i was like wow that was
a bike
definitely not as quiet as our studio
yeah like you know i was waiting for
like an hour and 30 hour and 40 minutes
and then i got to the front of line i
was just like wow i don't know if this
was even worth it or not oh bro you know
what i actually a game i played at
gamescon and that was like no line for
this is before cuphead came out and i
was like so [ __ ] hyped to play
cuphead right it was in like a 10 minute
wait i really like cuphead and i was
like [ __ ] yes this game is awesome
i can't wait to buy it and it was good
that was good but uh yeah so uh we went
to mcm we were there for three days oh i
mean connor and i were there for three
days
one day just because i had some things
to do in and out here and there so i
only wanted to commit to one day
um but yeah how was your first uk con
experience joey it was uh i mean we'll
get into the details later but it was a
lot of ups and a lot of downs that's for
sure it's very much a roller coaster i
mean like you know
like i expected like you know british
fans to be super chill and they were for
the most part um but of course you know
at the same time it's like this is our
first con as trash tastes right so it's
like i knew that like
my
you know my fans like the anime man fans
like british fans would you like chill
as they usually blaming trash takes you
i mean like
could you say that it was like a hundred
percent chill
i mean i i think it was for the most
part it was like okay so here's the
thing it was like 99.9
chill yeah you know but then you um
there were like those one or two people
that obviously really really stood out
and some of them even made waves uh you
might have even seen some clips online
about some of the people we've had to
deal with over the weekend yeah um
because it just like the intensity
was just like way more intense than
anything that i've ever experienced in
my life before oh like i'm saying yeah
yeah we enjoy we walked around on um so
it's a three-day comrade friday saturday
sunday and they have this odd ticket
system that i've never seen in any other
con where like every single day they
have like a priority ticket which means
you can come in from nine right and then
a general ticket which means you can
come in from i think eleven or twelve
something like that yeah confused about
that i didn't
i don't really understand it but um we
walked around on like friday at like 10
a.m before everyone got in and like we
could walk around it's pretty chill like
we got stopped a lot but i stopped every
now and then but like we could still
walk like we did
friday 10 a.m which is literally
the deadest time of the entire year
you're not gonna get a deader time yeah
yeah exactly in that time so at least
like you know i got to actually like
walk around even for a little bit to
like actually see what the con was like
in all the other places because it's
freaking massive isn't it yeah that's
really big it's just like it's like 20
warehouses just attached to each other
yeah yeah exactly but um yeah i mean
that was cool but then you know it's
very yeah once the actual like general
admission started to come in around like
11 12-ish yeah yeah it got very heated
very quickly very powerful so what was
your guys's expectation going into this
convention
i was expecting like okay obviously more
people are going to know us now not just
for individual stuff but for trash days
if anything there's probably going to be
more people who know us for trash taste
yeah yeah but i wasn't expecting it to
be like
10 times as much
no you know like i mean i had some
expectations obviously i expected more
like uh to be more recognized and
everything like that now that i've shown
my face more i've got an extra channel
now and just talk [ __ ] with the boys you
know
um but this was definitely like an
eye-opening weekend for me because we've
like speculated before about what what
an anime convention is going to be like
now since trash chases started i think
this weekend has definitely cemented
that anime conventions will never be the
same again
for us yeah and it's like it was like a
bittersweet realization because i
remember we were all it was it was a sad
day when we all realized this i think